this you bad [ __ ] coming direct
on a Monday afternoon Churchill what's
happening now breed [ __ ]
you know those kinds of alliteration
screams
you
oh [ __ ]
I'm bad oh [ __ ]
it's a fun-filled wet Monday I was
thinking about Wednesday it's a
beautiful day to be alive me and Lee
about to do a little [ __ ] podcast
with our friend Matt Baker from Matt
Baker BJJ we're going deep today with
some [ __ ] cushy mu she's and then how
come we don't get these when you're over
there they got tons of these high-level
ones why you keep beating stars for
sometimes the spooky 200 what's happened
you bad [ __ ]
yeah uncle Joey here you kill I was
gonna show up today those like Oh am I
in you [ __ ]
never never now we got [ __ ] edibles
that look like this we feel for how you
guys doing
I missed you over the weekend Omaha was
[ __ ] tremendous
done anything just like that no muss no
fuss two minutes later your eyeballs are
popping out of your [ __ ] head but who
gives a [ __ ] baby it is the 11th or 12th
of June or something
crash France we're gonna go to a
different level listen when I get
edibles they come right out of the
[ __ ] oven
I make friends with the people oh yeah
that's rip delicious the [ __ ] you think
you're dealing with here I went over the
perennial today I got two more batches
of reefer they're drying out in my car
right now
get nice and [ __ ] brittle for the
pipe of debt who would smoke with some
presidential which is still [ __ ]
tremendous when these [ __ ]
either Brody of Becky and [ __ ] bad
throat a short throat [ __ ] Friday
morning from smoking dope with some
stranger
just like that motherfucker's I don't
know what Trump said I don't know what
Hillary said but my heart goes out to
Orlando you guys know how I roll
I'm nothing but heart they had a big
dick and ugly face a lot of heart and
that's all that [ __ ] matters right
now Lee you want to hit this away are
you gonna sit there like a [ __ ] bumpy
Johnny [ __ ] CD over you like it
through you never eat CD again all the
way to Boston comes back would see
leaves 100 clams in the ocean
there's a hundred clams and a wait to
come home and this [ __ ] shows up
with [ __ ] baked ziti understand me
you think you guys think you got it
[ __ ] rough
it's a [ __ ] zero afternoon here look
at my manly sigh at Suge Knight's shirt
behind bars they put them in the black
section little usually give you black
and white stripes they gave this [ __ ]
Momo [ __ ] black shirts
oh [ __ ] I back [ __ ] all this
tremendous wood this [ __ ] hey listen
this [ __ ] presidential from
sunset oval and we're getting the
[ __ ] stars back tomorrow they get
delivered 11 a.m.
what man what that lets it happen
howling my [ __ ] attic
I'm gonna kill him a song to Italy gets
tacos cuz if I saw that show [ __ ] he
just realized now cuz the lettuce what
about the the rabbit and the [ __ ]
goat they put that [ __ ] taco you're
worried about lettuce you see I'm
dealing with people daily who goes there
to eat a [ __ ] burrito people die
vegan Hanley goes they poison his dad
unbelievable
well I gotta live with little Aerosmith
be one of the greatest albums of all
time in my world rocks don't get two
months it's all about heroin you get
rocks and dirt and melted down your
shoes in your arm you'll be high for two
[ __ ] years why not at this point I'm
ready to do a couple more weeks of [ __ ]
put the mule in the stable oh [ __ ]
she's a kook and put the eats on the
table we're going deep cuts e7e yeah
yeah let me see you [ __ ] little Jew
fingers to [ __ ]
I gotta watch this [ __ ] I want
your security guards if you're gonna
sell them a black do come to you gotta
walk away but you know Security's
eyeball now I see a black dude in
7-eleven that's my cue to start
shoplifting cuz all eyes are off me you
don't say
are you [ __ ] nuts or what sometimes I
just give a guy a fight I'll bill go in
there throw more if I gotta go on then
get a [ __ ] TV yourself you think I'm
kidding
look go you gotta use every [ __ ] step
you understand it hit it oh [ __ ]
shits get beat bust off the syringe
that's how you do it you either have
other you have to create a [ __ ]
obstacle feeder you blow up half the
kitchen I don't have no sticks of
dynamite or you show up with a black
dude you give them a friendly you send
to the hot dogs they watch them before
Arabs you ever see them they're like
those pictures at the [ __ ] Adams
family's house the head stayed straight
for only eyeball food and [ __ ] they
start watching that [ __ ] poor black
dude meanwhile he's spending 2 bucks I'm
shoplifting 19 I'm saying you glisten
that's American ingenuity right there
except the black guy in first
no no no these monkeys get the [ __ ]
soda I'm saying is I'm paying the
[ __ ] Sun waiting for $3
I give him a friend what are you getting
I made this [ __ ] mutt those black
dudes those homeless people hang
ourselves I mean they're looking for a
dollar some change you fellows
[ __ ] offend
they'll wash your car suck it dick
whatever [ __ ] you need I pulled over to
Easter I gave her a guideline like a
tense body almost died he thought I was
Jesus and a memory he's probably still
walking around looking for a [ __ ]
silver here we go [ __ ] we're
going on the rats in the cellar yeah
Jesus in the memory who gives a [ __ ]
somebody gives you a half a yard you
don't question though
oh yeah oh yeah baby boy the only way to
do it little reef in the afternoon break
up the monotony if not what he gonna do
go to a bar able to punch it drunk you
see the Stanley Cup last night
congratulations to the Penguins [ __ ]
it up I don't know how many years it's
been but if anybody needs a [ __ ] win
in their City
it's a Pittsburgh [ __ ] Steelers
penguin penguin Steelers you don't
[ __ ] up working in concert say the
Jews East Side West Side never told you
[ __ ] up you guys know when I get stone
like this morning I got [ __ ] stoned
to the gazelles I just I went to [ __ ]
meet these dudes at arts I had a bagel
and two bites I sipped the [ __ ]
Salmons like a straw oh my god are you
kidding me or what left my protein gross
[ __ ] cream cheese but you know where
they [ __ ] up those Mexicans get the
onions instead of red onion and then
give no case without lettin us both know
sighs - listen if I was a Jew I get your
[ __ ] set the ostrich right now but
since I love you and I'm a Christian
[ __ ] bring me the red onion I won't
tell nobody
they didn't bring cable don't give a
[ __ ] about capers anyway real Jews don't
eat cake does that some day picked up
over here in the states to be [ __ ]
cute still think real Jews don't eat
cakes
Wow
with your truck
with am Italian we're here we'll wait on
my man Catania 236 as early as a
[ __ ] where you baby this is I
think this is the second house by ellos
no no no no no none of mine I'm wrong
it's Aerosmith
the first stop and then you've gotta
down by the man that's a masterpiece in
my world call get your wings
and then I think us rock directly people
come on you know online let me give you
the trilogy of the Aerosmith [ __ ]
world 1976 were they not in the [ __ ]
with the Boston Red Sox not the World
Series is 7675 well alright what do you
think you're dealing with so for them to
put this our mount and 75 and anybody
give a [ __ ] you know sometimes say you
Boston hadn't even struck them to see
the playoff and I don't know how many
years they get into the World Series
against the Cincinnati Reds obviously
they [ __ ] lose but no nobody lost in
that series if you know anything about
baseball if you know anything about
baseball nobody lost in the 75 76 Series
between the Red Sox and Cincinnati Reds
the Cincinnati Reds were powerhouse and
the Red Sox were powerhouse the
Cincinnati Brett oh [ __ ] the Cincinnati
Reds
guys they're recording this nobody gave
a [ __ ]
I will speak was on heroin everybody
roll them out and they came out with a
brilliant [ __ ] how that's what I'm
saying brothers but they don't expect
something from you that's when you put
their [ __ ] your finger up their ass
only [ __ ] lot of people expect the
last minute
you know I have no idea what I'm talking
about I'm just either guilty but my
favorite stone on the sound is a song by
name but nobody's fault
it says [ __ ] Joe Perry masterpiece
we'll put it on after this just to let
you [ __ ] known for John's [ __ ]
around
listen roley's danke suck my dick lonely
still no know nothing about nothing they
know about Justin people that's it 176
on the grade who gives a [ __ ] about
Rolling Stone this is the top three
albums in my world because if you listen
to it when you listen to it you could
smell the heroin if you read the book by
element I think it's the first one when
they all describe chapters they talk
about the making of the sound they
weren't even talking this is why it's
not this is real [ __ ] rock nobody was
talking they were too busy behind it you
put your name on the [ __ ] cannot list
and that lets you go into the studio and
report by yourself they lives in a big
house and Worcester or something and
then recording studios in the basement
they be doing bags the trilogy's eat
NASA's you think these people are home
drink and tell milkshakes that make
shitty [ __ ] music you understand me
if you're at home eating kale and you're
a musician you're gonna die of [ __ ]
starvation just but I'm gonna do that
for you
you got do the H my line yeah a couple
food salutes you gotta go out at night
you got to get bump into bad ass you
gotta fall in love gotta be heartbroken
you gotta live a life Prince we think he
sat at home we made that sexy music cuz
he was having threesomes with Runaways
every Monday night
yeah level three someone to run away
they cry and put it you gotta hit him
with the suitcase
I still got a [ __ ] even that [ __ ]
at 3:00 in the afternoon
ya gotta help with the suitcase I'll
call your mother just having a good time
here [ __ ] if you can't take a
joke take a show I don't give a [ __ ] no
more dog I'm 53 I got one foot in the
grave one a banana peel had a
three-year-old that drives me crazy I
got this [ __ ] guy bringing ziti back
from Boston I'm saying you need your
[ __ ] cracked me before you crack me I
crack you [ __ ] I've been through
psychological torture Vietnam can't do
dictum II understand
that's why don't you leave that nummies
food that will [ __ ] around people I'm a
loyal soldier but you know what it's
that time it's that time for another
bone of death let's put on the other
side don't go away don't go nowhere I'm
to switch yourself I'm back [ __ ] like
cancer anyway oh [ __ ]
another masterpiece
feeling good saying I took my seat beat
the oil i rub some on my fungi toenail
I cut the fungi told our last night I
found the mushroom under I will not even
do mushrooms no more we're just gonna
eat my [ __ ] toenails and see what
happens
same [ __ ] difference understanding
I'm gonna have a raffle eating one of
joeys toenails see how high you get you
free you gotta go at least 14 15 hours
you sweating [ __ ] think of the
Chinese people [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
sick as a dog I wish you [ __ ]
could smell this you understand I also
wish you to smell the fart life blasted
in here before the [ __ ] periscope
came up I had to wait five minutes to
get the [ __ ] out of my [ __ ]
you have no idea you have no ideas
[ __ ] wait the math the Hat Baker
jujitsu extraordinaire coming in the
reason I like Maddie's got a lot of
[ __ ] Hardman people that do what he
does have to be [ __ ] it have to have
a real good belief system and anybody
who has a real good belief system you
gotta hang out with someone somebody
comes to me and believes on what they
add and they don't do it for money
that's complete just a [ __ ] game
you'll be the last to see me Ron sick as
a dog what's your story
what the cat got your tongue
what do you guys expect magic drinks
this [ __ ] this is it this is my life
chill with my [ __ ] dog is the number
one [ __ ] Jew in the world
again
today's show is dedicated to the people
who lost their lives in [ __ ] Orlando
it's a [ __ ] terrible tragedy I don't
have the solution you know people don't
do what they want to do I just feel bad
because they're human beings may God
bless them enough I hope their entries
easy into the next world because there
is the next world you know all right
[ __ ] I'm switching off on my
truck to my mat mat bake this and we'll
see you [ __ ] at 3 o'clock